make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and we are returning once again to
our series on how to kill superheroes
and today's installment focuses on one
of the most powerful entities in the dc
universe
the spectre so the spectre was created
by jerry siegel and bernard bailey and
debuted in more fun comics number 52 in
1940 so he's been around
for a long time since the golden age of
comics now the first explanation of the
spectre's origin centers around a
policeman named jim corrigan who
is murdered while on his way to an
engagement party now the first
explanation of the spectre's origin
centers around a policeman named jim
corgan who's murdered while on his way
to an engagement party stuffed into a
barrel filled with cement and thrown
into a river now when corgan's soul gets
to heaven he refuses to pass over into
the afterlife so the archangel michael
attaches his soul to a spirit of
vengeance and sends him back to earth to
dispense divine judgment to those
who committed acts of evil for 60 years
now back on earth jim corgan returns to
the police force and takes up a career
as a crime-fighting superhero called the
spectre and as a character's popularity
waned the spectre was turned into a
background character whose purpose was
to provide comic relief before
completely disappearing from dc comics
for about 20 years
now although the character would be
revived and show up periodically
throughout the silver and bronze ages it
wasn't until the 1990s under the writing
of jon ostrinder that the character
would really find a renewed popularity
ostrander sought to reinvigorate the
character and work to tweak his origin
and add to the mythos surrounding the
character when he revealed that after
corgan was murdered in the 1940s he was
not actually resurrected
but in fact remained dead although he
walked the earth thinking he was still
alive after being bonded to the spirit
of divine vengeance ostrinder also
revealed that the source of the
specter's powers is actually god himself
and that the specter as an entity had
existed since the creation of man and
was actually the embodiment of god's
wrath now over time the spectre had come
to reject the idea of mercy and so it
was bonded to a series of human hosts
and hoped their humanity would temper
its wrath
and corgan was merely the latest in that
line of hosts we also learned that the
spectre was previously an angel named
aztar and incited with lucifer during
his rebellion but after repenting for
his betrayal receive the role of being
god's wrath as a punishment and so what
makes killing the specter such a
difficult endeavor well as i stated
earlier this spectre is one of the most
powerful entities in the dc
universe he's omniscient and nearly
omnipotent immortal capable of matter
and reality manipulation
time travel and telekinesis and so there
isn't much that's outside of the
specter's ability to achieve
he's proficient in magic and is able to
turn humans into trees and pillars of
salt and is said to be a far more apt
sorcerer than dr fate who's thought to
be one of the most powerful
proficient magic wielders in dc he can
alter his own size to massive
proportions at one point becoming so
large that the distance between his eyes
measured 23 light years his energy
manipulation powers are so vast that he
was able to create a supernova in the
palm of his hand
the spectre's ability to manipulate
reality has allowed him to neutralize
the effects of darkseid's omega beams
and was able to forge a nexus that
linked all realities
he was able to break through the source
wall a feat that was thought to be
impossible and is battled with the
anti-monitor during crisis on
infinitives produced enough energy to
destroy the entire dc multiverse and
created a new status quo in the form of
an entirely new universe referred to as
new universe and so the question we have
to answer is how to kill a being of such
immense power well luckily for us
despite
me saying that he is immortal earlier
the spectre can and has been killed
before he is immortal in the sense that
he will never die of natural causes or
old age but there are actually a couple
of ways that he can be killed the first
is by a being that's able to wield magic
to a sufficient
degree while this seems simple we need
to keep in mind that the amount of
magical power that would be needed to
destroy
the spectre in its entirety is
incredibly hard to achieve
as i mentioned earlier dr fate is
considered one of the most adept magical
sorcerers in the dc
universe and he was unable to muster
enough magic to defeat the spectre in
fact the mesopotamian deity that is the
source of dr fate's magic
also known as naboo was actually killed
by the specter which prompted the
presence the supreme deity of the dc
universe punished the specter in turn
now while it may seem extremely
difficult to find a source of magic
strong enough
it's not impossible the spectre is
nearly omnipotent but not
totally omnipotent meaning that there
are limitations to its power he can be
weakened by expending energy and in a
weakened state he becomes more
vulnerable to magical attacks in fact he
was killed by eclipso the entity that
was the embodiment of god's wrath
prior to the spectre taking over that
role now how this came about was that
eclipso brainwashed several members of
the justice league and caused them to
attack the specter with the specter worn
down
eclipsa was able to slice him in two
with his mystical sword and absorb his
essence unfortunately it's going to be
difficult to wield as much magic as
eclipso who despite not being one of the
most well-known villains in dc comics is
definitely among the most powerful
however i do think that this offers us a
clue
into a way to kill the spectre firstly
we're going to need to mount an
offensive of beings with a sufficient
enough power level to require him to
expend
a great deal of energy fighting them at
that point we capitalize on the
spectre's weakened state and
vulnerability to magic by using an
artifact of divine or mystical power to
deliver the killing blow
one such artifact that comes to mind is
the spear of destiny the weapon used to
pierce the side of jesus christ at his
crucifixion now the funny thing about
this is that the spear of destiny does
exist within the dc continuity and has
been used against the specter with
debilitating effects one of the other
crazy things
is that the spear actually came into
possession of the american president
bill clinton who gave it to superman to
slay the specter who was raging out of
control at this point and it was thought
the spear of destiny was the only weapon
in existence
capable of taking the specter out and so
as it turns out the sphere contained a
corrupting influence
placed in it and it threatened to
corrupt superman before he rejected it
and so the specter then encased the
spear in a boulder and sent it into
space
luckily for us the spear has since been
retrieved from space and was later
purified by the question
so if we can come into possession of the
spear we don't have to worry about being
corrupted and i really think that using
the sphere is our only reasonable chance
for success
short of having the presence himself
battle the specter as he's able to
exercise absolute control over him since
the spectre is effectively an extension
of the presence
and so that's how i think that we would
do it let me know what you guys think
down in the comments section i'm really
curious to see what ideas you guys come
up with if you are new here to comments
explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and i will catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
me